je rappelle la troisième de cette étape
comme base soit le seul à la fed a perdu
deuxième main mais qu'elle s'allie sera
suspendu de cible le correcteur
cwi officié pendant les quinze gedimat
lagarrigue une équipe encore pour le
moment celui-ci à ce parti dit que ces
clubs
ce maillot sera quand il parle de 5,65
gonzalez inscrits et 260 miller qui me
recevoir ce beau maillot rayé ce mardi
mexicain porteur du maillot bleu et
opéra lyra les siècles soit bayrou jours
pas plus pas mal aussi à deux décès etc
soit meilleur je peux cette 37ème
édition du tour cycliste international
de partir là-bas you pay est patronné
par le cas des motards plus près de
vénissieux sur des épaules au trône aux
côtés de leaders de ce maillot c'est à
distance du siège 28 développe le
bailleur à bouche le maillot du meilleur
grimpeur a patronné par servir qu'en
pense le tirage de la péninsule à ty des
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
le manioc la patronne et parfois je
place ma ba ouais on aura au vainqueur
du jour de cette deuxième étape à 1205
ou des roseaux made in furs gedimat la
gare nous fournissions le
conditionnement de signaux
c'est une application
et puis j'espère qu'on va gagner notre
activité pour l'universel